[Music]
hi everyone
thanks everybody for joining today this
is avinash dharmiya
i'm a senior principal application
scientist at perkin animal
today i would be presenting on
overcoming challenges associated with
analysis of pesticide microtoxins
regulated by corridor state in hemp
using a novel
lcm sms method with dual
esi and apci line source
this slide shows the outline of my
presentation
first i would talk about different lists
of pesticides and their action limits in
different u.s states and canada for hemp
and cannabis matrix
next i will show you how we analyze some
of the non-polar pesticides such as
eclia diazole quintozine
cyhelothrin methods and few others using
our novel lcmsms method with dual ion
source
next i would talk about ionization
mechanism of non-polar pesticide with
hci ion source
later on i would
show you how we mitigated hemp
medication effects with healthy and ms
method optimization to improve method
sensitivity
in the end
rationale of our of our sample
preparation method
which was automated uh simple solvent
extraction
with good extraction efficiency
less cost and higher throughput and we
added a number of internal standards
which are available from part number
region hit to improve method accuracy
so different u.s states and canada
regulate different number of pesticides
for hemp matrix for example
there are regulations for 59 pesticides
in oregon state
66 pesticides in california
96 pesticides in canada
and 102 pesticides in colorado state for
hemp matrix
even for the same
pesticide the action limits are very
different in different u.s states and
canada for example
for asygnosis
the actual limit
in oregon state is 2 ppm
0.1 ppm in
in california state and 0.03 ppm in
colorado and canada
so as the number of pesticides increase
and the action limits becomes more
stringent
we have to improve our method
continuously
to analyze a large
panel of pesticides with lower detection
limits and
matrix to meet
the new requirements
therefore in my presentation i would be
showing you today that how
we improved our existing method for
66 specified regular california state to
meet
more stringent action limits
by colorado state for 102 pesticides and
5 microtoxins in hemp matrix
so we are analyzing all the 102
pesticides and 5 microtoxins with
different polarities using an lc-msms
system with a dual esi and epci ion
source
if you use a single source lcm service
system
it takes a long time to exchange
esi with epci ion source and vice versa
using our dual esi and apci ion source
system
we can analyze
both polar and non-polar compounds by
switching from one source to another
very fast
the next slide shows the structures of
non-polar pesticides such as methoprene
and cyhaloplane using our heated
electrospray ion source in lcms in the
system
so next slide shows that we get
excellent detection limits for psi
hybrin in hemp
if you look at the structure of this
compound you will notice that this
compound has
very low
proton affinity it is a non-polar
compound so we had to optimize both our
ion source
conditions and mobile phase composition
to improve detection limits for this
compound to meet colorado state action
limits of 0.25 ktm and n
also in the past
a lot of people have asked me how do we
determine our loq
for different pesticides so these yellow
cubes which i'm showing here
were collected by pre-spiking
hemp matrix
for all the analytes
also our loq numbers are take into
account the 10th
dilution factor
using our sound reputation method so
when we say
the loq in this case is 0.05 ppm that
means that
the hemp extract had a concentration
about 10 times lower
about
0.005 ppm when we were measuring this
compound using esi iron source so we
account for
both the dilution factor of our sample
precision method which is 10 and we
piece by 10 matrix to determine these
alloque numbers
so in this example we are showing that
we get excellent detection limits for
methoprene and hemp
if you look at the structure for this
compound it is a oxygenated hydrocarbon
therefore this compound was only
analyzed using gc msms in the past
but using our heated electrical spray
ion source we can get excellent textural
limits and our method loq is 0.1 ppm
which can meet colorado state action
limits of 2 ppm in hand very easily
so this slide shows the structure of
non-polar pesticides analyzed using apci
iron source
if you look at the structure of these
compounds namely echediosole and
quintusine you will notice that they are
non-polar and habitated
and therefore these compounds were only
analyzed using gcmsms in the past
therefore i am very excited to show you
the next set of slides because we can
analyze these compounds using epci ion
source without the need for gc msms for
this analysis
at your diesel is another pesticide uh
which
is very non-polar
and chlorinated
it has very uh
low protein affinity so you cannot
ionize this compound with good
efficiency
in positive on board using both esi and
epci ion source
therefore we are analyzing this compound
using apci iron source and negative and
mode
this slide shows clearly that we get
excellent loq of 0.01 ppm for this
compound and we can meet very stringent
colloidal state action limits of 0.03
ppm m for this compound
so among different uh non-polar
pesticides analyzed using both esi and
epsilon ion sources in our method
quintozine is the only compound which
can only be ionized with apc iron source
for other compounds we can ionize all
the non-polar compounds using both esi
and epsilon source
it might be possible that one compound
will ionize better with esi or or it
will ionize better with apc ion so based
on the ionization efficiency
we choose an ion source to analyze that
compound
but only for this compound we do not get
any signal with esi iron source because
of its
uh structure we can only ionize this
compound using apci ion source
and after optimizing our method we get
excellent section limits of 0.005 ppm in
hemp
also not only our method is sensible but
it is also very selective for this
compound
using apci iso so if you look at the red
rays
which is obtained using the blank and
matrix you will notice that a blank hemp
matrix shows very low signal it only
shows electronic noise
it does not show any matrix interference
p at the retention time of window z
and we get excellent signal noise
for quintessen even at a very low level
of 0.01 ppm enhanced so our method is
both sensitive and selective for
quintusine and other non-polar
pesticides
using apci iron source
next i would like to talk about the
ionization mechanisms of non-polar
compounds with apci ion source
so it is very well known the most common
ionization mechanism for different
pesticide is called
proton extraction
uh
in negative and mode which results in
deprotonated molecular ions for
pesticides with acidic functional groups
like fipronil or fluorocarbonyl
for other pesticides we could not form
uh defooted molecular ions so we had to
determine new ways of
ionizing these compounds and new
ionization mechanisms
so
for example for pesticides such as
chloride
we are
forming adduct ions in negative ion mode
by anion attachment
for a signal style it gets ionized by
electron capture
to form odd
electron ions which is very rare
when you ionize these molecules with esi
and apcr ion cells normally you form
even electron ions
for pesticides such as ethiodeozole and
chlorophen fire
we are ionizing them by difficult
electron capture so in this
mechanism they capture an electron which
is followed by dissociation into a
fragment ion and neutral molecule
among these different molecules the
ionization mechanism of quintozine
is the most interesting and unique
in this case we believe that oxygen gas
captures the electrons
formed in a coronal discharge region of
epsilon source to form superoxide
reagent ion
this superoxide reagent ion reacts
further with quintosine molecule to form
an ion
by loss of chlorine and addition of
oxygen atom
in the literature sometimes this
mechanism is also termed as dissociative
electron capture with substitution
so hemp matrix is a very challenging
matrix for pesticide analysis it is a
complex matrix it contains more than 500
different compounds including
more than 100 cannabinoids and 200
turkeys
some of these
cannabinoids and terpenes might be
present in ppm to percentage range
and they can get co-extracted with trace
level of pesticide during sample
preparation method and cause matrix
effects or matrix interference when
they have same retention time as your
pesticide or mycotoxin
so next i would like to talk about the
strategies we deployed to reduce these
hemp matrix effects to improve our
method sensitivity
so one strategy is to
is to optimize our ms method to reduce
matrix interference and thereby
improving method sensitivity
so when you see the this light
on the left you will notice that when we
use
imrm transitions based on the monoi
isotopic mass of 342 for octane result
we see a lot of matrix interference
but when you see on the right when we
use
mrn transitions based on m plus 2
isotope of propaganda's old
then the red test shows that the matrix
interference is minimized
and we can uh improve our detection
limits by a factor of ten
i would like to point out that the
mrn transition based on the monox w mass
has the best signal in solvent
but the detection limits are poor in the
matrix because of the matrix
interference
uh but when we use a mrn transition
based on m plus two i could talk of this
molecule
it has two chlorine atoms so we are
losing the signal by 30 percent
but we improve our detection limits
because we minimize the matrix and
difference by factor of 10
therefore by just changing our mass
transition we can improve uh the
detection limits by factor of 10 for
this example
next i would like to show an example of
endosulf and beta
with apci iron source
so on the left when we use the fast six
minute lc gradient for endos and beta we
observed
75 ion separation for this compound
and our method could not meet colorado
state action limits of 0.05 ppm
for this compound in hem matrix
but on the right when we use an optimum
11 minute gradient
with our ioc method
now we were able to uh minimize our ion
suppression effects they were almost uh
insignificant
we were able to improve detection limits
by factor of 10. now our method loq is
0.01 ppm and can easily meet colorado
state action limits
next we wanted to understand why we were
able to
reduce these ion suppression effects by
just changing our ylc method
so what we did was that we collected
apci ion source negative scan
data for hemp matrix to determine the
retention time for cbda which is the
main cannabinoid in m matrix
this hemp matrix we use had about six
six point five percent cbda
so on the left what you observe is that
when we use the fast six minute lc
grading method
both endosulf and beta and cbda coeloud
and
and therefore cbd is causing ion
suppression effects for endoscope and
beta
on the right when we use an optimum 11
minute lc gradient then
we get
base separation of both endosulf and
beta and cbda because their retention
times are now different by
0.1 minute and therefore this way we
were able to reduce ion suppression
effects
for endoscope and beta just by changing
our lc
method
in another example
i would like to show you that we just
changed the iron source to improve
detection limits for the pesticides
in the beginning we were analyzing a
signal style
uh in hemp using esi iron source so
after
carrying out different optimizations of
our method we were getting loq of 0.01
ppm
recently we we can
we tried to measure this compound using
api ion source so we were able to
improve the detection even further
0.005 ppm so now our customers can
analyze this compound using two
different iron sources to improve
their confidence in analysing this
compound
in the beginning i thought that both
these methods are equivalent for
asynchronous style
but as i extended my method uh
for this compound in different uh hemp
matrices
apart from
plant
matrix such as concentrate and hemp
or cbda or cbd based edible products we
are noticing that apci method is
better than esi iron source method for
this compound because
it has better
sensitivity and has less matrix effects
in comparison to esi ion source method
for this compound
this is the example i wanted to show you
was for acrylotoxin a uh
the
the actual limits for ocratoxin a are
the lowest in cholera state in
comparison to
other u.s states and canada
the action limits for this compound in
hemp in colorado state are 5 ppb
whereas
action limits in other
u.s states
and canada is 20 ppb for this mycotoxins
in hemp
so to in order to meet uh lower reaction
limits for octotoxin and hemp
using esi ion source we had to optimize
both our ion source conditions and on
the left we can see that we change our
mobile phase composition and we were
able to increase our signal by a factor
of 5 to
7 by with the new mobile phase
now our method loq of 4 ppb
can meet
lower
colored state action limits of 5 ppb for
this compound now
now i'm going to switch gears and i'm
going to talk about the sound
depreciation method we used
to
analyze both pesticides and microtoxins
from hemp matrix using our lcms ms
method
so we could have used any of these six
different sound proportion methods
but i would like to audience ask the
audience let's say they have six
different options
and the criteria for choosing an option
is that you know it has to be
simple faster cheaper
greener
and can be automated and shows good
extraction efficiency for
all the
compounds
then
i would think that everybody will go
with the option which can meet this
criteria
so when we look at all these different
sound decryption methods only
simple solvent extraction with acn
extraction
met this criteria for some method to be
simple faster cheaper greener and can be
automated with good extraction
efficiency and that's the reason we
chose this simple sample preparation
method
as solvent extraction in our method
so this slide simply shows the different
steps in our simple solvent extraction
method with overall dilution factor of
10
we grind our hem sample
uh using uh omni uh
homophobicizer
and we add uh acetonitrile solvent to
extract pesticides and mycotoxins we
vortex centrifuge and then filter
our
hem sample to get the final extract and
then spike it with a small amount of
internal standard
now i would like to define some terms so
when you are choosing uh
your sum proportion method and you need
to
determine uh how good it is you have to
determine the extraction
efficiency extraction efficiency is
determined by taking the ratio of the
signal in pre-spike extract to post-site
extract
this slide shows that our
sample preparation method shows
excellent extraction efficiency for all
the 102 pesticides and 5 microtoxins
from hemp
matrix in the range of
80 to 120 percent
if you zoom into the data you will
notice that about 97 percent of analytes
have extraction efficiency which is very
close to 100 percent
so this slide shows the comparison of
extraction efficiency obtained using our
solid extraction sound reputation
method with other three different
sample preparation methods used in the
literature for five pesticides
only our simple solvent extraction uh
method shows extraction efficiency close
to hundred percent
for all the five analytic analytes
for comparison if you look at the
extraction efficiency for one of the
pesticides paradigm with the four
different sample friction method if you
use
uh questions with dsp the extraction
efficiency is 68
if you use a solid extraction followed
by
st and dsp then extraction efficiency of
pitodin is about 58
and if you use the solvent extraction
followed by evaporation then
you can't even determine your extraction
efficiency that means almost close to
zero percent
only our simple solvent extraction
method gives you an extraction
efficiency of 95
for this
compound so if you are losing anywhere
from 30 percent to 90 percent of this
analyte using the sample decryption
method using the other three different
sound profile methods
that means your method sensitivity and
accuracy will be compromised by 30 to 90
percent
but this will not happen if you use our
simple solvent extraction method
so once you have determined the
extraction efficiency of your sample
preparation method and
if it is good then the next step is to
determine the matrix effects using your
sample preparation method so how do you
calculate that
essentially you take the difference in
signal obtained for an analyte using
uh postpipe extract and the solvent
standard
and you divide this number by signal
obtained for your analyte in the clean
solvent standard
so if your analyte
experiences a matrix effect which is
less than
negative 20 percent that means it's
experiencing significant ion suppression
effects
or signal suppression effects
if your analyte shows a matrix effect
which is greater than positive 20 that
means they are experiencing
uh significant signal enhancement
effects
so this slide shows the hemp matrix
effects for
different analytes measured with esi and
apc iron source method
as a functional retention time
you will notice that most of the
analytes are
are experiencing
signal suppression effects with the esi
ion source
and signal enhancement effects with apci
ion source this is expected because uh
apci ion source shows less matrix
effects in comparison to esi iron source
for different analytes
also since hemp matrix is very
hydrophobic
and this is expected that the most of
the matrix effects are observed for
analytes at a high retention time using
reverse phase lc columns
so we are adding a internal standard
solution uh
containing 30 of them
uh in our sum precipitation method
to improve our
method accuracy because these internal
standards can
compensate for these hemp matrix effects
these uh 30 internal standard solution
is part of a perfume or pesticide
reagent kit
which also contains certified pesticide
and microtoxin crms and consumable items
to prepare your samples
at this point i would like to define the
accuracy which is
taking the ratio of the measured
concentration and your spike
concentration
the next slide shows that we can
improve our method accuracy by
compensating for hemp matrix of x by
adding internal standards uh to our
sample proficient method
so this is a busy slide what you will
notice that uh
when we don't uh add internal standards
to our method
about 30 percent of analytes have
uh
very poor method accuracy outside the
idle range of
70 to 120 percent
but when we add internal standards to
our method
we get excellent method accuracy in the
range of 70 to 120 percent for all the
102 pesticides and 5 microtoxins in
matrix
if you zoom in the data you will notice
that except for one pesticide
all the other 101 pesticides and 5
microtoxins have an accuracy in the
range of 80 to
120 percent with the addition of
internal standards
also uh as i mentioned earlier in my
presentation we can also uh
both
automate our workflow and sample
question method with janus workstation
to improve uh reproducibility
and also we provide cloud connectivity
and traceability with our workflow to
get you closer to certification
and here's a
short video of our automated workflow
for pesticide and microtoxin analysis
and
matrix using our new product called qs
works
perkin elmer has created a complete
end-to-end cannabis testing solution to
fully test the pesticide residue and
cannabinoid testing on cannabis samples
to ensure regulatory compliance
connected through the simplicity lab 420
cloud system this high throughput
solution utilizes the janus g3 420
workstation the qcite 420 lc msms system
and reagent kits to ensure a
reproducible testing solution
once the cannabis has been received and
weighed samples are fully prepared using
the janus g3 420 workstation
utilizing standards and reagents from
cannabis reagent kits the janus g3 420
workstation can process over one hundred
samples per shift and uses a barcode
reader
and eight tip very span arm
mdt gripper
vortex
and centrifuge to autonomously prepare
the samples for the q site 420 lc msms
system
the samples are then analyzed using the
qcite 420 lc msms system and the quality
of data is reviewed by the qc manager
once complete the results are uploaded
to the simplicity lab 420 service
fully connecting all parts of the
process through the cloud the simplicity
lab 420 service enables complete sample
traceability and compliance submission
to limbs or regulatory frameworks such
as metric
perkin elmer's end-to-end fully
traceable high-throughput cannabis
testing solution will empower you to
accurately and reproducibly test
cannabis samples
[Music]
this next slide shows our method lfq and
corridor state action limits for 102
pesticides and five microtoxins in hemp
matrix
in each column the first number shows uh
our methanol q the number
in the bracket shows that colorado state
action limit for that analyte
a number of analytes are marked with a
star
so those analytes were measured using
our apca ion source method the analytes
which don't have any star
to them
they were analyzed using electrospray
ion source method so if you look at the
list you will notice that number of
non-polar pesticides such as methyl
green canopy
quintozine heterodiazole and maybe
20 to 25 more analytes were analyzed
using gcm sms in the past by using our
novel lcmsms method
we can analyze these
non-polar pesticides and polar
pesticides and mycotoxins
using uh our novel uh lcm sms with esi
and epc iron source
now our customers don't need gcm sms for
this analysis
now they need only
one scientist
one instrument one set of consumers and
one sample proficient method
to reduce the cost and complexity of the
analysis
when they
want to you know use our method
in the end i would like to summarize the
key points of my
presentation
we developed a novel lcm sms method with
dual apci dsi answers which can analyze
all of the 102 pesticides and five
microtoxins regulated by
collateral state to meet their action
limits and hemp
we elucidated the ionization mechanism
of different non-polar compound with
apci ion source
matrix interference and matrix effects
were minimized by ms and lc method
optimization and by changing the mode of
ionization from esi
to apca ion source for few compounds to
improve our method sensitivity
solvent extraction is a cost effective
sample preparation method which
can be automated using our janus
g3 system
to achieve high throughput and with
excellent extraction efficiency
we added a number of uh internal
standards in our method which are
provided as a part of a pertinent region
kit
to compensate for hemp matrix effects
such as iron suppression enhancement to
get
overall accuracy in the range of 70 to
120 percent
i would like to thank a number of
colleagues and scientists at perkinemer
and different cannabis testing labs for
helpful discussions with them
i would like to thank the audience for
the attention and i will be glad to take
a few questions
from you
you